[Music]
strength
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
never tell me the odds kid
[Applause]
welcome back to the break room our daily
show that keeps you updated on just
what's going on in the nerd news from
our very own real break room and by the
way we are getting a lot of comments in
the comment box about people who work
here that would like their break room
back but they can't no because we're
celebrating
the break room we're celebrating may 4th
we're very excited thank you to everyone
who sent in those amazing cosplay
pictures using the official break room
hashtag
and our break room you want to get to us
you want to get to meet
you want to get to me
you hashtag nr breakroom and i'll
respond saying thanks thanks for
reaching out uh anyway i'm tommy beck
told i'm here with my uh
my my team of bandits and misfits and my
hive of scum and villainy brennan
barrett hello
that's all i got jessica clements it's
[Laughter]
[Applause]
you know what i have to take out that
thing is surprisingly heavy yeah no
wonder he was always in such a bad mood
yeah that's why that's i think it's
because he had to deal with lena dunham
[ __ ] on girls
oh not that kind of show inside baseball
wow we got to swear yeah hit that ticker
speaking of swears that's a good help
there are two ways for you to give us
money honey or to you know support the
show one there's that dollar sign and
that's a tip or you know you can buy a
sticker or a super chat i'm looking at
every camera john's probably going nuts
can we look at this one john microphone
we're getting a lot of okay we got to
wind that mic up okay listen
you hit the dollar sign that's a super
chat you buy a sticker you send us a
comment you say hey zach do a funny
dance we make him do the dance okay the
second option is you can do exclamation
point tip yeah is that correct
exclamation point tip sends you to our
tip jar which is our swear jar and
that's what's going to incentivize us to
say those nasty nasty cuss words all
right
and we're not talking dank ferric okay
we're talking fs and q's
js
you know and we're talking j-o-n and
f-b-n and all that okay we're gonna do
everything
but you gotta hit the swear jar and
that's done by hitting exclamation point
tip which will take you to a separate
page there's been a lot of confusion
over that but we're gonna make this so
simple for you again six easy
steps dollar sign you simply contribute
to the show
exclamation point tip to contribute to
the swear jar
we're getting the thumbs up from john
and that can only mean one thing it's
time to announce what's coming up on
today's show
sam raimi's plan on making spider-man 4.
we'll talk about that multiverse of
madness trailers showing up too much uh
okay we never mind i read that wrong
multiples of madness trailers showing
too much according to daddy fi he
yes moon nights wild finale remember
that
a little fourth grade show and tell from
us intro hosts i've already done it
swear jar
tips and rules already done it guys i
would like to start today's show though
with an apology
[Laughter]
yesterday i slandered the seattle
seahawks much to the chagrin of jessica
clement's family i
lost her mother and i lost her brother
and i want to say i'm sorry to the great
franchise in seattle the 12th man
marshawn lynch and all the beast mode
bandits up there in seattle my heart's
with you and i wish you the best with
your quarterback drew lock this year
[Music]
you made that face
becoming more and more a sports show
and one other apology real quick
i want to apologize to all the mothers
out there when i suggested that taking
moms
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness would be a terrible mother's day
gift it would be a great mother's day
gift if your mother was into doctor
strange or just benedict cumberbatch
at mom's club marvel movies and i didn't
mean it that way i was referring to my
mom specifically whose idea of a
personal hell would be three hours in a
movie theater with her favorite baby boy
watching a movie that made no sense well
now now uh marvel movies are four
quadrant movies yes one quadrant is uh
angry young men one question is lovely
moms you gotta
what what's two of the other quadrants
uh hot babes that like to wear princess
leia bikinis and of course the fourth
quadrant uh prepubescent 12 year olds
falling in love with angelina jolie
during eternals uh and then there's the
fifth quadrant where my mom lives which
is was this written by mae binchy or amy
tan uh and if it's not she does not want
to go see it is maeve [ __ ] a real
name [ __ ] is an irish author who i
believe passed away about 20 years ago
but she writes uh some great novels and
let me tell you my mom was a real maven
maeve uh maeve maven anyhow let's get
back to the show uh we haven't gone too
far off the rails i think it was a great
idea to let me try i'm sure that'll
happen a lot more
the thing we need to talk about is it's
may the fourth and we all know the big
news today is that kenobi trailer
dropped baby
and you know what we said i got a text
in the morning that was like alert alert
alert do not watch do not watch like
didn't so we all got together
before this shoot to watch the trailer
and here's a live look at our reactions
okay we go
fans
green clouds
we're back in the blade runner city
[Music]
hello there yes
[Applause]
okay
i like her
she's smart i want everyone who
translates come on
and a fun drawing boys
daddy daddy's home
daddy's home
and we're all in the same seats and one
guy is wearing the same shirt as before
this morning
well we got bunk beds in the back we
sleep here we eat right that's right we
watch trailers here that trailer was
obviously much more of a uh gave us much
more information than the first trailer
uh god thank god for eric voss and i for
our for our side project wikileaks we've
been thirsty
thirsty we've been in the sands of
tatooine talking about our favorite you
know droid oils and now we can finally
talk about something a little more
substantial
all right guys we got to talk about this
trailer it's time to uh it's time to
address how much do we think uncle owen
is working to keep ben away from young
luke i mean he was pissed yeah he was
pissed but also that was just a
conversation i'm not saying that
everyone should just you know pull out
a lightsaber or something but
it didn't seem like i feel like uh he
can get his way not like in but i feel
like obi-wan can be like talk his way
out of it though we know
uncle owen wins
right yeah everyone doesn't interact
with luke well i'll go and lose this in
the you know what hell that's right
loses back well he wins until he loses
sunburn at some point
yeah that's going to be an interesting
because because we know how it's going
to end
that kind of removes that dramatic
tension from the series right we know
obi-wan during this series is not going
to meet luke so like that that's going
to be an interesting thing to portray on
screen but he does like luke knows of
him right because he's the one that's
like oh do you think they mean old ben
kenobi yeah right up in the mountains so
it's like i'm sure they interact
sometimes i'm sure
owen hates it and owen probably says to
luke like don't go
talking to that kenobi guy so of course
luke god knows what luke thinks that he
actually did like luke is probably like
i don't know what's up with that guy
maybe he sells spice yeah yeah yeah
maybe he's spicy
he's got death sticks for sure oh yeah
he smokes
uh hate those but yeah it is interesting
to be see uncle owen like so
antagonistic and like maybe he's sick of
this kid i don't know maybe like luke's
maybe luke's a lot maybe he's you know
forced throwing things around and he
doesn't know what he's doing right you
know right right he could be sick he's
trying to get his wife out of nexium
with keith bernary yeah
so real life sleeping in there oh yeah i
think it seems like uh
like you guys said he's very angry and
he blames
uh ben kenobi for losing his brother and
like you know it's like what a dig yeah
what a dig just like you did as far as i
mean
who knew uncle owen yeah i could spit
bars like that and i decided to get like
a little more into like what the hell
uncle owen was all about because luke
didn't seem i mean like the whole in the
in a new hope obviously we don't have
all the information we have now but luke
just seemed kind of like your average
teenager that wasn't like miserable he
just was like wanted more he wanted
something more exciting so now we get to
find out a little more about what that
home life was what formed what like
shaped him as a child so i'm looking
forward to seeing more of that but guys
we got to talk about another
another theory question we have here
what do we think kamal nanjiani's role
is in this film because he pops up for
just a second and it's right after the
moment that we hear we need all of the
bounty hunters like to help or whatever
whatever the exact line is i don't know
i feel like he's working with obi-wan or
trying to i think he is against the
inquisitors okay i i don't think he's a
bounty hunter it looks just just from
the outfit elements we saw it's very
jedi yes right yeah yeah yeah that'd be
sick to have him be a jedi yeah
it is interesting because there's got to
be other jedi still out there right we
know like they're hiding or whatever but
like do they even why would you look
like a jedi like you wouldn't want to
wear the robes you wouldn't want a dress
like one maybe he's like your powers
like in rogue one there was the guy who
was like a
fanatic yeah yeah he's like a fan he's a
fan boy a jedi stan i was surprised to
see camille's face because i if you i
assumed he was going to be like a uh
uh a droid or something like just put
his voice in right something like that
right yes that's what i that to me
was although they didn't announce matt
barry we do have to acknowledge jessica
just got up and walked away yeah she
poured out
technical difficulties nothing it was
nothing that brandon said uh she did not
agree with that theory but like i mean
before book above effect i don't think
matthew berry matt berry was announced
in the cast right right i think that was
like a surprise voice i think when
they're just like
because i mean like tycha
was a major droid character in the first
season of mandalorian but i think
matthew matt berry we would all agree
was kind of like a fun little like one
or two lines an episode sometimes not
even in so to have announced kumal's
name i would have thought it would if he
was going to be a droid it would have
been closer to the
um
uh uh taika droid or the or the alan
turing yeah yeah he's like imperial yeah
exactly character that he played i guess
we just got to move on without
darth maul i don't know you know he's
happier he's happy
yeah and apparently um being what
species is small
remember remember
i should sorry uh but apparently being
that species does make it difficult on
your mic pack uh yeah oh so what we were
gonna say will we see yoda in this
series oh yes i wonder
i i bet like i would go with like a yoda
hologram or something like a message
or get hand delivered or something like
that i like that oh
i feel a disturbance behind whoa there's
always two
the best part was jessica put on his
makeup right after the show ended
yesterday yeah she slept
where were we at we all went all out of
here talk about yoda are we going to see
you
that's not canon
well i mean i don't know we already are
getting so many established characters
in this show we know even down to uncle
owen right like
i don't know that we need more yeah yoda
would be packing in uh a lot of uh
things that fans want to see but i want
to see him i think that's what it is is
the argument of like do i want to see
him yeah but also like it's a it's not a
lot of it is a lot it's big returning
people but there's a lot of new people
so i think it's okay to bring in yoda if
you wanted to because it's like the only
other people that we're bringing in are
a couple
did yoda go straight to dagobah ah see
that's what i don't i don't i need to
know more about the extended materials i
think i if i remember some of my comics
yeah and this might be post disney
buying there right he
yoda was scrapping around out there
doing a couple missions yeah he's
getting to get his hands dirty and dirty
hiding a couple jedi here and there yeah
i mean he feels yoda right he's the one
that's like super depressed because he's
like i missed everything yeah he's like
i should have seen it all oh yeah i was
in charge
this happened under my administration
like what a mess yeah what um all right
but we gotta go back these are good
theory we gotta go back to the trailer
okay from what we saw in that trailer
what do we think this show is going to
change in the star wars canon
that's tough right yeah um
i think they're beefing up
vader and kenobi's interactions prior to
a new hope i think that is getting a
vitamin b12 shot
of like let's let's really hammer home
how much these two hate each other by
the time or at least yeah vader hates
kenobi by the time he kills him or
kenobi lets him kill him also spoiler it
could just be adding and getting ready
for osaka uh tanos
like i mean i don't think it'll be too
much but i think she can still refer
back to it if something happened where
it like it
tangentially connects to her her show
yeah and like you know to our uncle owen
conversation it might put a lot more
weight on the little we see of them in a
new hope yeah knowing what they go
through in this film a little bit yeah
on the show
it could make us feel a little more bad
for them getting burnt to a crisp right
that's not that we didn't already feel
bad i feel about these shows though are
like like they add and they make you
care more even more about these movies
that we love that we saw as kids yeah
you know
it just it it enhances the experiences
and speaking of an experience being
enhanced it's hard for mandatory fun
whoa
whoa play my graphic whoa there it is
yes
mandatory fun
yes today
as we all know and as we've been doing
for three whole days mandatory fun is
what i make my friends have a little bit
of non-optional joyriding with me and
today we're going to do some star wars
show and tell but first i have to have a
bad announcement to all of you oh uh i
asked you all to bring a special item in
here but unfortunately
i have to go you have to go
is this related to when jessica had to
go a couple minutes ago uh it's similar
but i have been called away on another
mission and uh i have arranged
for a wonderful substitute teacher to
help teachers oh okay okay
you guys can just you know quietly talk
amongst yourselves i'll go try and find
him okay
every time tommy leaves and the sub
shows up
it's usually someone that is outrageous
powerful whoa
yeah is there maybe like a disturbance
in the force or what could be making a
powerful could be a disturbance and how
we pay the power bill i don't know
oh wow oh mood lighting a little mood
did it just turn red are we yeah are we
having sex
if we need to
if we need to ask if we're having sex
it's not a great sign
is that pallbearer what's happened here
it is i the emperor
and i will be substitute teaching this
class oh
everyone must show me what they've
brought
for show and tell
uh what's going on with your face this
is my face there's nothing i can do
about it um i brought something amazing
oh sure only did i bring
cookies wookie cookies i brought a
wookie with me today a wookie yes i
brought wookie cookies everybody close
your in your nostrils
close your nostrils do the wookie
cookies smell
the wookie cookies do smell like wookie
cookie food
we're about to see uh
oh are we getting a cameo from office
dog oh it's a walking oh it's bubba fett
oh my gosh
that's terrible yeah so that is my
showing good show-and-tell it's you in
town just wait until brandon pulls out a
parakeet yeah yeah oh
there are many show-and-tells that folks
around here find
unnatural
this is a very unnatural show-and-tell
you know what's unnatural the smell of
those dog treats
it is unnatural uh well well uh your
excellency what do you call the the
emperor you may call me emperor pal
and i pulled out something that's uh
really the bane of my wife's existence
a small fraction of my star wars
hallmark ornaments
this is this is just a small taste of
what i have to offer uh every christmas
time when the the tree comes down you
know most people they put a little santa
claus on there they put a little uh uh
you know some angels maybe some turtle
doves no no my tree is all it's all ip
baby and these are collectible items
uh we got lots of callers on the phone
right now we have several of these items
available these are collectibles guys
i mean this one's from the 90s baby
my do you get one a year i get it i get
at least one a year
well hallmarks they got me by the uh the
death sticks you know what i mean like
uh they make one out of the collection
the collectible one and the other ones
our guests are like quasi collectible
but i mean guys what says christmas like
a little princess leia uh forced into a
golden bikini on the tree with a giant
axe speaking of
tell santa to keep his hands to himself
i'm feeling unnatural right now okay all
right palpatine all right
keep it in your back to tank yeah yeah
but yeah this is but a small fraction of
what and what about you okay well i have
um this is uh oh this is a special i
don't know if it's collectible on the
level of a hallmark ornament but this is
a comic-con exclusive
hot wheels um star wars set they took
the
things from the attack on the death star
it's like the trench run the trench run
they turned them into cars
now it used to light up and make noises
uh the battery has exploded inside of it
but that doesn't make it any less
collectible and any more any less dear
to my heart and true star wars fashion i
made the batteries explode i have been
the exploding batteries in your head the
whole time
now uh pal patine do you have anything
to show and tell what
the well are you gonna participate yeah
you you want
you guys want me to participate
but i'm
i did bring a little something oh okay i
love emperor palpatine so much
okay i think he's struggling a little
bit uh not great visibility forever
jeff's got cataracts
i brought a little animatronic grove oh
that's adorable oh
he's doing a spell oh he's so cute
oh he's enough to make you go from the
dark side to the light side it's enough
to make you
not me never i've got to go
i've got planets to destroy oh
my palpatine
[Laughter]
that is adorable uh while we wait for uh
palpatine to get our buddy tommy back
let's shout out a couple of the uh super
chats um
xavier said uh jess your outfit makes me
wanna turn to the dark side
i do love as jessica was uh transforming
herself into darth maul uh she did shout
out at one point to me zach are my
eyebrows gone
they were turns out they were um oh
tommy you're back oh hey guys i hope
everything got got settled okay and
while you leave oh come on
again you know what just like the real
darth maul you never want too much you
know i mean just enough to keep you
wanting more wow huh
well what did i miss guys oh it was a
great time yeah your substitute was a
little rough oh yeah yeah yeah he wasn't
as nice as you said he was gonna be so
highly recommended on my professor.com
yeah
i don't think it's a real site uh
speaking of real sites though
we got a real site called epic
heromerch.com
there are emerge partners here at new
rockstars and at the break room actually
this shirt i'm wearing this is the way
uh with the cool dark saber uh i believe
you can get that at uh epic heroes shop
they've got great merch including um
they recreated that trucker hat from the
thor trailer that uh strongest avenger
right and they've got some cool uh dr
strange uh wanda all kinds of loki
hawkeye all the marvel series from
disney plus are represented on there
there look at that nice little chiron
down at the bottom uh check it out and
keep an eye out there they're about to
drop very soon they're about to drop
their multiverse of madness latest
obsession shirt um i want one of those
when it comes out um also new rockstars
is on tumblr
we're going to talk a little bit about
moon night today but we're talking a lot
about moon night on tumblr find us at
newrockstarsofficial on tumblr and by
the way we should mention
when we get to moon night we will give
you proper warning yeah we're going to
try not to spoil too much but there will
be some spoilers involved so if you have
not seen the episode yet for the love of
god and we will tell you yeah yeah you
should go
get yourself some oreos and milk dunk
them while we're talking well we're
dunking on some of the things that
happened in that finale
no we loved it we loved it also bless
your heart if you took an hour out of
your day to watch us and you didn't take
an hour out of your day to watch
moonlight that's right thank you thank
you for that
um okay but we also have some headlines
part of this show every day at the break
room is that we're gonna cover there it
is look at that nice graphic
uh we're gonna cover the news of the day
all the fun nerdy things that you might
have missed uh that you want to hear
about um we'll start with some upcoming
disney plus marvel news uh our buddy
michael waldron we call him our buddy mt
didn't get to do an interview with him
uh he has been on the new rockstars
channel whoa okay i think another
disturbance in the force just happened
um it was announced that he will uh not
be on season two of loki he was the head
writer of season one of loki he wrote
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness one of the writers yeah one of
the writers yeah there's always a team
uh he will not be the writer of season
two he's being replaced by eric martin
who was a writer on season one and he's
kind of come from the same dan harmon uh
writer tree he worked on community and
rick and morty and in all of those shows
so uh
you know no reason to think this is
anything other than writers moving
around yeah i think they're they're real
hot on michael waldrop right now i think
you know they like to wait down loki
they bumped him up to the films but
they're keeping them in the well there's
a lot of precedent with that with like
uh marcus and mcfeely right right they
just kind of you know moved them on up
from agent carter and other things so
yeah yeah michael waldron is just a
hot man okay
oh
okay
well hello
um uh kevin feige uh our lord and savior
uh speaking at the multiverse of madness
premiere
mentioned he was going to ask like
what's your favorite moment in the movie
and he was like uh there's been too much
in the trailers i don't want to talk
about it
which is is that him sub tweeting the
marvel marketing department
he's president of marvel studios right
so this would be disney yeah that's what
we're talking about is like disney in
charge of the marketing because they own
the marvel properties and he doesn't
have as much say
you know is he frustrated like because
he has to deal with sony also who does
their own marketing and like all this i
did love uh uh our producer dodson had
like a great conspiracy theory behind
like the reason they showed like uh
captain carter yeah the teasers is so
that haley atwell could go
are you in this movie are you in this
movie like i can't talk about it which
is like a really funny way to think
about it yeah it's like well
her agents negotiated that they're like
get the shield in there put the shield
in she wants to go it is interesting and
like we can all kind of see kevin
feige's point of view like yeah is the
14th trailer really getting anybody into
the theater that wasn't convinced by the
first through 13th trailer right we need
to show clips of every scene every fight
every character yeah probably not right
we're all sold we're all going to this
movie you know i'm sure there's a lot
that is still in the movie that isn't in
the trailer but i think kevin feige was
like my favorite part
plus plus we know as we all know from
morbius and we don't have to go into
anything about the content of morbius
but the trailer
was a complete misdirection from what
was in the movie there was gotcha yeah
well that's just a lie like what if none
of this was in the actual movie with
that was in that movie for
how long
a couple lines he had a cup of coffee
i wanted to be in there a lot more uh
sam rainey
broke our hearts uh recently in an
interview saying he has currently no
plans to make a spider-man 4 with tobey
mcguire
i mean that means he hasn't been paid
enough to do it yeah or he's just like
toby said he doesn't want to do another
so he could do a different spider-man
yes
samurai's been doing a lot of interviews
obviously leading up to multiverse
madness and it's great and one of them i
think it was with the hollywood reporter
he was talking about like how he loved
seeing like toby in
uh spider-man no way home and being like
oh i recognize this
character he you know what he's
portraying i can see the sadness i can
see the pain
you know it must be nice to be like i
made that that's that's my guy yeah
that's my guy i built the foundation on
which this house is is built yes and
we're feeling a little bit of a rainy
sense right now yeah okay
he hasn't made a movie in a while right
before uh multiverse of madness so maybe
this could launch to other things maybe
he's also thinking about dead movies
yeah
also uh the evil dead video game came
out and i'm sure he had some some hands
in there like he had to have some little
kind of love it drag me to hell too or
make nothing maybe they didn't okay
you're you say that almost daily that's
my evening mantra
uh oh we got some kenobi updates fitting
for our may the fourth episode we got a
new poster john do we have that poster
look at that wow
that's gorgeous
i want that for myself darth right yeah
get the red saber give me that that's a
great looking poster okay so that's a
cliff
okay you guys you know i don't have
glasses on that's a cliff right right
and his chest
okay
wow
our department's always knocking it out
as a part over there that looks great
who was it sorry this is a side note
that i just love i think vaz mentioned
it and was just like we have the finale
of moon night and all this kenobi stuff
dropping at the same time and that
poster dropping right when we're all
like figuring out what's happening at
midnight i was like what do i look at
first where do i go yes there's so much
disney why would you make everything on
may 4th everything it's it's christmas
in may uh
i'm sorry i don't interrupt you zach
you're doing such a wonderful job i just
want to remind everyone because looking
at the totals it appears as though there
may have been another miscommunication
it's exclamation point tip to go into
the swear jar
uh
and then just the dollar sign button if
you want to do a super chat or you know
ask us a question or something or you
know tell jessica how wonderful she
looks or you know ask me to tell you my
darkest secrets maybe people don't want
us to swear yeah maybe we need to
rebrand the jar maybe the jar needs to
be like a secret jar or a confession
or a jar jar oh that's what it should
have been an accent or an impression jar
what if it was an impression jar
everybody donate we have to do an
impression of something or make an
impression that wouldn't leave an
impression
sorry zach no no no no problem please
tell me interrupt me anytime you like
and i mean that genuinely that's not a
passive aggressive shitty thing to say
i think it was there's a sweater
um oh uh another couple of headlines red
hat chili peppers bases flea
will appear in kenobi
it was announced so not only camille
showing up we're also getting flea in
there which he has done some acting work
yes brandon you're a big fan of his
appearance in um uh the chase
charlie sheen charlie sheen we love him
back to the future
oh i loved him in uh big lebowski yeah
it was one of the uh uh there weren't
anarchists what were they called
nylons he was one of the nihilists flea
was the guy who races him in his truck
remember he pulls it up and he's like oh
rachel
and then he fires him and he's just
boston back to the future
uh a great pop fig figure pop culture
figure known i mean just for slapping
the hell out of that base and wearing a
sock to cover his penis and nothing else
but also uh has a pretty impressive
filmography yeah
also for two things
you didn't ask me what my favorite oh
sorry apologies yeah
can you guess what my favorite part the
croods no close okay you were very close
it's the wild thornberrys oh that's what
i meant that's what i meant it's not in
the
that's my impression of donnie and it's
very good i can do that really well and
uh
and uh i can do r2d2 really can you do
that again
let's hear the r2d2
you got to save these for the impression
like that when my brother was pretend
fighting me and he was like you sound
like r2d2
so if you ever want to rob me you can
hear that impression again
okay don't incentivize people to rob you
but you know what
it's out there now
also the red hot chili peppers are
currently like going on a tour so oh
well i guess they shot kenobi yeah
oh it's possible maybe a long time ago
playing the base i'm going to throw hell
yeah
because then it's like the people that
are like my nephew who's 11 watching
this would be like what was this yeah
i heard uh flea voiced all the
lightsaber noises
what did they sound like
[Music]
[Laughter]
did you tune in today thinking we'd get
a solid five minutes out of fleas
[Music]
bad news
well i you know that's enough flea talk
i think for the rest of the week uh it
is time for us to discuss the moon night
finale so if you have not seen the moon
knight finale
turn away mute the mute we'll put up the
spoiler warnings we're going to talk
about the finale of moon knight if
you've got if you've got your own
questions about the finale of moonlight
drop them in the chat we'll see if we
can get some of them up on the screen uh
what a finale guys uh
this this is your spoiler warning we're
gonna get into it now uh what a pretty
crazy finale i'll say uh you know we
must be getting like a season two of the
show right we better go they called it
we've we've talked about on the show
they called it a limited series then
they submitted
they submitted for the emmys as a
limited series but then there was that
tweet where they called it a series
finale and then they deleted that tweet
and they called it a
just a finale
the thing is you can't we're spoiling
right we have the borders yeah we got
the the spoiler board can't have jake
lockley finally show up at the very very
very end and then be like no season two
because it's like even if he does show
up in werewolf by night even if he does
show up in this we're gonna have this
unresolved conflict from jake from
season one of moon night you can't just
throw him into a different series you
gotta you gotta go over it i need i need
it or they could do a moon night movie
oh
they could make a moon night movie i
don't think anybody they just had that
retreat they planned out the next decade
you know is there well and that's a good
question or a good point tommy it's like
so far movies theaters series disney
plus is there a day where they make a
movie just for disney plus and they're
like we're not going to i mean we're
getting we're kind of getting that with
the guardians of the galaxy holiday
special the werewolf by night halloween
special i mean probably like they're
probably gonna be closer to an hour long
but they're probably working towards
that though of doing like the disney
original music movies disney channel
original movies but doing it for disney
plus yeah and i mean
yeah i think moon i would be a good a
good first for them to start with that
one because they got it i think moon
knight wasn't expected to be like the
biggest hit that it was and now like
after this finale it was trending
everywhere and it wasn't just like moon
night it wasn't hashtag moonlight it was
hashtag konshu like it was specifically
a character did did kanchu guide you
might get into a hashtag if not can we
start that actually
they were they were big and they were
touching things right they were
physically they feel like they hit the
pyramid there was
a shot where you see the truck move so
like they were really they're doing that
people see them yeah kanchu was always
able to like push you know he pushed
those cabinets and stuff in harrow's
home base and no one could see him no
one could see him but they could see the
stuff get moved they could see stuff get
blown away
uh i'm sorry
oh okay we got it john we're about to
have a cameo from uh producer director
john
issues right now we're having some
microphone problems that's how you know
the show is live right all the
conspiracy theorists in the chat saying
it's recorded
um
okay yeah well let's get let's get uh
thanks john
fan john yes
jets mafia j-e-t-s you suck
okay get out there all right
so yeah that that's a great point like
the i loved the the giant gods fighting
bumping into pyramids kicking stuff
people must have been able to see them
right yeah no no i don't think people
got to see them i think it was i think
only because i also don't think uh the
followers of arthur harrow could see
ahmet i think only
well
no cause leila couldn't even see it were
they too busy looking at their dad being
raptured because he has a pornhub
subscription or like what was going on
there well that's a great question so if
you can't see the gods
sorry real quick i do think actually if
you have a pornhub subscription that
makes you a good person all right if
you're just using porn up for free maybe
that's why you're here with me
you're watching it with me over at
redtube.com that's not an endorsement
we'll leave that up to the gods to
decide
so could everyone see the purple
souls coming out of bodies i think i
think so because that's what they were
looking at right when they grabbed the
people's hands so they see a purple
people can see purple souls going out of
bodies going into the air funneling
ghosts
disappearing they can see it
ghostbusters
also i don't i think it was very weird
that arthur harrow was not clocking that
the dead guards were coming back to life
as tolerate like i took it that he
couldn't see him maybe
that one of those shots made it seem
like he saw him looking over it
yeah the dead bodies are talking about
that voice
like they've been so she can't fully
yeah she's like pushing air out of you
whatever air is left out yeah i loved it
i loved it i loved that first like be my
avatar and she was like nope oh the
transformation and she's talking about
her dad and i love that going back and
forth that actress was so fun and this
last episode i was like congrats yeah
yeah you got it you got you got not only
did you get like the everyone wants that
merch of the hippo everybody wants like
terra witch stuff and i'm like not only
did you get the best god you are you
yourself was a really good fighter yeah
and that costume was fantastic
also
thank you and ahmed they had a
relationship with somebody clearly there
was a lot of sexual tension there was
some tension well they worked together
and they'd mentioned that at the
beginning of this year they were
they were they worked together well and
even all that stuff about like we want
the same thing
yeah no we don't right yeah we do like
we should be working together no you go
too far like they are so closely aligned
and yet also adversarial i mean kashi
was definitely dipping as papyrus in the
company campaign
too easy that release of god you lock it
in stone and all you gotta do is
smash let's let's look at some protocols
that's the case i released a ton of gods
at my grandma's house when i was a
little kid because i was knocking
statues over here
i really saw the gods of humble
little jerk a lot of precious moments
sir floating up into the guardians of
the sheep of the field
i think you mentioned this offline once
about like osiris avatar just like
wearing a suit in this like cave and i
just like the fact of like they were so
surprised when arthur harrow came back
and apparently defenseless right like
had nothing
wimpy white magic which i've already
talked about was wimpy uh and they
started school
the next shot was them doing like the
family guy fall on the stairs and i was
like damn they are broken yeah that was
that was very disappointing i wonder if
that was a centerfex budget thing where
they're like we can't have a giant like
uh any ad battle then have a giant
conchu versus ahmet battle that oh
simultaneously it made me wonder can the
other idiot not heal their avatars like
consciousness oh right is he the only
one with that ability yeah or were they
just like yeah we need to do it i don't
like that i will say and i
i liked this show the multiple levels of
logic that needed to be working at every
given time did feel like i did not keep
up wait why okay so wait the you need an
avatar even though the gods can fight
each other and giant and like what makes
you big and
it was enjoyable i just let it wash over
me at a certain point because trying to
figure out why things were happening and
how you defeat something got a little
confusing uh i will say i feel like
people could see the kaiju kanchu
circle r trademark
um only because if they if they wanted
us to think that they couldn't usually
they give you that shot yeah of like an
empty night sky followed by the shot
from like arthur's point of view where
you can see the shirt but i think that
we would also get that shot of people
reacting to it and no one was really
reacting they just stood there if you
see a kaiju like we did in suicide squad
two you run the opposite direction well
we definitely got the crowd reaction
shot when the kind of very uh
ghostbuster z like purple laser going up
from the top of the pyramid when
arthur's up there kind of summoning
everything that's what i think they were
looking at was that that purple thing on
top of the period i mean they're not
going to run a couple days ago this guy
was spinning like that it's kind of it's
been a rough time egyptian yeah
[Applause]
to the cast here um
if if this season right was kind of like
an elongated origin story
like what is the next story we want to
see
i'm pointing at uh support your local
gui guillotine
great name first off said hot take jake
will be the villain type character in
the next series or movie he had no
problem killing a nurse to get hera out
of the hospital and i completely i think
that is that would be where it goes next
is like they're what's that what's above
fighting a god fighting yourself so it's
just like that is the best line of
uh good ones here hot take what if
kanchu is being
capable of multiversal travel and found
jake in a different universe oh that was
from page flicks art oh like so he could
have
like margaret steven are still there
and jake is another
body well but then how does that explain
the blacking out yeah
and the line that mark has no idea how
damaged he is so that kind of to me
implies that mark is the actual
per like who's the person he's the alpha
right and that yeah here's what i want
and i will answer my own question that
seemingly i was posing to the group but
really as an excuse to prompt myself um
i
i like this series i will say i would
love to you know what we didn't get
really in this series is like
moon knight as this avatar of justice
out there going defeating bad guys we
actually we know he did that before the
series started because we saw all those
dead people on the boat or whatever
right but like i want to see him do that
i want to see him go out there and find
a kidnapper and you know rev him up or i
want to see him go like hunt down
killers and stuff like that and do some
kind of ghost ridery spirit of vengeance
kind of stuff well he had an avatar
doing those things for him still right
well what country did but i want to see
jake yeah or stephen or martin as that
avatar today yeah i want to do some real
questions
honestly disney plus should do like a
short like they do with like the peter's
to-do list and like all those other
things they should do a short that is
just like jake and conch or if you don't
want to do
a
full-on moon night season two do a
falcon and winter soldier type thing
where it's moon knight and scarlet
scarab or moon knight and blade or moon
night and
marvel team-ups yes let's go
[Music]
that's awesome
too it's like what did layla see
when when they went the full jake during
oh yeah clearly she was
did the outfit you think the outfit
changed yes i feel like he also said
goodbye in spanish and she was like
and they yeah they don't show this to
the audience in the show but it's like i
hope mark slash steve and sat her down i
was like all right explain to me exactly
what you saw
what my accent was
and did i put on a jaunty cap
and i went dude
you notice the the stretch that
uh jake drives off in says spectre yes
on the on the vanity plate which that's
interesting so i mean mark had to
register the vehicle before his super
conscious i need you to sign a few
documents i took it to mean that like
whatever
jake lockley's uh moon night persona is
because you have like moon night you
have mr knight
i was thinking his is called spectre
well i mean you can't afford the vowels
on the license plate you could only get
so many limiters or the possibility that
jake is so devious that he is aware of
mark and stephen and knows that if he
impersonates mark
maybe there is no jake lockley to the
outside world maybe only conscious knows
jake lockley but jake lockley just
pretends to be mark spector i like that
books yeah i like that 100
i like that 100 what was our next
question
um
sky breeze yes said you guys think when
ahmed said quote time's been horrible to
you that concho used to actually have a
feathered bird head like in the comics
so do you think he was not always a bird
skull he used to have the feathers
and it seemed like they made a point
like ahmet had like some kind of
tattered cloth or kind of almost
mustachy whispers along yeah that's a
snout right like uh that they have kind
of aged even as but even the skull
doesn't
open and talk which i think is
interesting it's messy in the bottom
part isn't it i thought it was just kind
of bonded there but maybe you're right
maybe the bottom jaw is always like
his new neck right clearly it doesn't
need to be anatomically correct if it's
a head of floating above shoulders but
what could have caused
a full if cancer had a full bird head at
one point what do you think caused like
the desecration whatever banishment he
faced like stripped
also just fighting all the time because
amit's just like yeah they come to me
and i get to decide well you folks in
the chat who own birds at home you know
at times of stress they pick out their
own feathers
how many of you just have a couple
skulls walking around instead of these
days
let us know call in if you're if you're
listening
uh we'll get the chat down below uh oh
can you read that thomas yeah thomas
briscoe jr he said i would like to see
gelatine if you've ever played marvel
contest of champions you know what i'm
talking about i have the gelatine gelat
glad i don't know i i have no mt's the
one that's playing the uh marvel contest
of champions i have not played it okay
and we'll get back to you uh kenny kenny
c asks are all the statues gods released
now which ones will we see in the future
that's very interesting because like the
crash happened right so it's like the
other day
temple's falling apart she breaks out
tower wet but i don't know if any of the
other ones got broken out well also just
because the avatars of those other gods
die
the gods are so out there the guys are
still alive those guys can pick new
avatars right yeah it's it's not a
two-way street there right i also don't
think the other gods and i could be
completely wrong because one seemed like
this but i don't think the gods cared
that much about their avatars the only
person that really cared i think will be
terroret and also country with jake like
they don't really like i don't think
osiris gave two
craps about his student man no clue he
was like deuces he gave him a terrible
looking just magic thing a little like
white wispy magic as brandon has said
yeah and white gave him a basic [ __ ]
forever 21 suit
we're way behind on the swear jar uh
elena bernstein asked can we talk about
how ahmed didn't care about the scales
very interesting part when she was like
nah i need a baddie in my side i don't
need like someone balanced yeah i want
you because you're a yeah i i want
someone who's bad to do my badness
almost like she knew what she was doing
was bad well
she said that sorry the one who betrayed
her right was balance yes which might
have been the greatest
did we ever determine that alexander the
great was the one that led to her being
ready
no because he was already dead when
they're shoving her uh ushapti into his
dead body right
that's a great point
yeah that's a good point
later but i i do like that because it is
like it's the subtle difference between
her and country she's saying the ends
justify the means right and and you're
saying no no no no until until he does
say that you should just kill narrow
yeah but that that is actually a
question i have that is not in our thing
but i'd want to know do you guys think
that
when uh lockley shoots harrow do you
think he's still bonded with the meat at
that point that's what i'm wondering
i cause i was like did you just release
on it i don't understand yeah i i saw i
think what they talked about no because
ahmed got sucked into him right but by
the shafty rules if you break the vessel
like it gets released right no but they
made a point of saying he you can be
harmed yeah you're in a flesh vessel
that's why country wanted him to kill
right hero right there because then that
will kill ahmed right so i'm saying do
you guys think that by the time harold
was in that hospital was in the asylum
ahmet had already found a way to escape
possibly oh it's like i'm just what i'm
saying is do you guys think ahmed is
dead
yes now because she got shot in the face
but i do i see what you're saying now
with the hospital
and i don't think she did yet because
she still needs the avatar and the
avatar is in a wheelchair thinking
coffee is sand so i don't think that's
true at all when we tipped when he took
that cup over it was not sand yeah it
was coffee it was coffee just like lost
boys yes
maggots michael you're eating worms
you're eating worms
um
daniel roarick pointed out that the car
left in the end credits was also a
rolls-royce spectre is the car
thank you who pointed that out uh daniel
roarick
nice nice daniel daniel my brother
yeah can i read this know a lot about
cars
thank you for that random fact
yuka said i think the season finale was
rushed i needed maybe one or two more
episodes that's why
for me felt underwhelming love you guys
and just oh i love the channel i had to
kind of you were leaving with uh yuca
prieta i uh
i thought that before the post-credits
scene i was like
i don't know for the chaos of the first
five episodes of this show this is kind
of a
like an interesting kind of like uh
slow landing into the lake of uh
of of a of a season finale potentially
series finale so i guess i i don't know
what i wanted i don't know if i wanted
jake lockley to have been discovered
before the post credits have a bigger
impact on the player i think i just have
kind of a bias against post-credit
sequences because there are people like
that's not a guaranteed view you know
what i mean like if it doesn't happen
this is so i'm sure people are going to
say you know
rip on me but it's like it doesn't
happen in the actual episode i feel like
you're risking it not being absorbed by
the audience yeah tommy agrees with you
and luckily we have the breakdown yeah
it's coming out today with spoilers yeah
yeah eric uh well the inside marvel
episode mt and eric is already up on the
channel eric's breakdown will be coming
out on the channel tomorrow or he'll go
into depth i'm looking forward to
re-watching the whole series me too as a
whole you know i always kind of pick up
you pick up different thematic elements
doing that and i i think this series
will be rewarding in that sense come
back tomorrow we'll go into more detail
we'll have some more kind of thoughts on
moon night yeah we'll also be talking
doctor trains the multiverse that is
we're seeing it tomorrow night together
nope not me because i'm seen in i'm at
okay all right
and then friday will be our kind of
spoiler weary
uh multiverse of madness yeah spoiler
free we won't go into sports on friday
we talking we'll be talking mom but not
going into not getting too deep into mom
we still gotta cover her but by monday
we're gonna be in mine we're gonna go
we're gonna we're gonna be all in mom
okay and we also still this week we we
got to resolve our predictions we made
yeah we got to make it
a lot of fun we'll have to pay out thank
you all so much for joining us for all
the first three days of the break room
for joining us on may the 4th yes for
sending us all those great um cosplay
pictures yes thank you and thank you i i
razz you all about the appropriate way
to use the swear jar and the and the tip
button but sincerely thank you for
everyone who contributes to the show it
helps us keep everything going it helps
us buy fun little guys like him
he says thank you and it helps us buy
wookie cookies and the great great smell
of them thank god there's a w in front
of that because just plain ookie cookies
those ain't for anybody what's an oaky
cookie don't worry about it we'll see
you next time
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you